[Music]
so yeah this Smartwatch is
$69 but but before you type it is it
though is it really that nice is it that
good I feel like we should defined good
first because going into this I was
thinking just the fact that you can get
a fully functioning Smartwatch for $69
in 2023 just that by itself on its face
was kind of amazing cuz we live in a
world where you can spend hundreds and
hundreds of dollars on a smartwatch but
clearly there's a wide spectrum of what
these things can be capable of so this
one just the simple stuff right just the
basics the time notifications step
counter heart rate calorie counter sleep
tracking just just on its face that's
good enough for 95% of people right well
let's just start with the basics here
this is a square Smartwatch it's got
this orange silicon band that comes in
the box and it feels surprisingly
similar to any other smart watch band
and then it's got a 1.96 in diagonal
display the color is metallic gray but
the the material here is definitely not
nearly as metallic it does say aluminum
alloy on their site but if you didn't
tell me that just holding it I would
swear this is 100% made of plastic on
the outside but you know at least it's
coated in a sort of a matte finish on
the back part that's touching your wrist
around the heart rate sensors and then
there's some Engravings with a bunch of
text in the nothing font like the model
number and the headquarters location
which happens to be cheap inside London
which is very appropriate honestly it
doesn't look or feel terrible but it
just it clearly has all the obvious
shortcuts of a cheap product the more
you look closely at it you know the
bezels are thick and also weirdly uneven
all the way around uh there is no
rotating dial just a single shallow
cheap feeling button right above the
small tinny speaker to the side and no
fancy Puck to charge just usba to dual
Pin cable that comes in the Box it
magnetizes to the back which in
hindsight I guess is just as convenient
as a a fancy Puck but you know a little
less elegant looking but I guess the key
here is all of it works and it's solid
like the brightness outside it gets up
to 600 nits uh there's no auto
brightness though so you got to change
brightness manually like this but hey at
its Max it's very good indoors at least
and the whole thing is ip68 water and
dust resistant which is first of all
great if you want to go out and sweat in
it or go out in the rain but also wasn't
there a long period of time where
OnePlus and nothing products didn't get
IP certified cuz it cost too much extra
but now the cmf watch has it but then it
all works with the cmf watch app on your
phone which is where all the data gets
sent by Bluetooth so honestly there's
not too many different clever ways to
design a watch UI so you know if you get
a smartwatch if you've used one before
you'll basically already know how to use
this one so your watch face is your
starting point and then you can swipe
through Fitness data which looks
surprisingly like Apple watch Rings it's
got your heart rate history for the past
24 hours the weather is there in that
simple dot matrix way plus sleep time if
you use it to track sleep then a single
press on that plastic feeling button
will take you to your app list which you
can view as a grid or as a list and then
there's a good amount of apps in here
that just come on the wash so an
exercise app that has a ton of different
exercises the blood oxygen app which
gives you your measurements whenever you
want you've also got a phone call app
and yes you can receive phone calls on
the watch and that tiny little speaker
will crank out audio as loud as it can
to facilitate a real conversation uh
there's also a music app which gives you
just music controls for whenever
something is playing on your phone
there's even a camera remote app which
it doesn't actually open the camera app
on my phone or show a viewfinder preview
but when I do have the camera app open
the shutter button does actually work so
there's that there's even a voice
assistant app which if you open it
basically just opens Google assistant on
your phone and then uses the mics and
speakers on the watch for you to
interact with it the Find My Phone app
is hilarious though uh it only works
when the cmf app is open or running on
the phone so if you've just closed the
app it will just ask you to open the app
on your phone but you don't have your
phone but when you do actually open it
so it plays this max volume ringing
sound which will allow you to find the
phone which is pretty cool as long as
you've got that app open or have opened
it recently and I will say the UI on the
watch itself it feels like it's moving
around pretty quickly and not too much
waiting time to actually open or switch
between these apps mostly because
they're very lightweight like this thing
is basically just a Bluetooth accessory
pinging little controls on your phone
and then it's got watch faces and the
watch faces have a nice little variety I
think this one's probably my favorite
with the orange theme and a secondhand
moving slowly in a full circle down here
I feel like I'm pretty impressed it's
also very lightweight not that people
always value lightweight in watches but
in this price range they're pretty much
all going to be made of plastic so you
might as well lean into it and this
thing is super light so if you're doing
sports or just running around it's yeah
it's kind of out of the way and then
because it's a Bluetooth accessory and a
pretty generic one you can use this
actually with basically any Android
phone so you just grab the Play Store
app which has a 3.1 stars and it does
have some connection issues occasionally
for me but even that sort of
availability at least on any Android
phone is better than Apple can say about
their own Smartwatch and it gives me all
the basic info I'm looking for from
heart rate history to workout summaries
honestly it's not so bad when it's
working so I'm also able to do sleep
tracking since that only really requires
the heart rate sensors but I also
continue to get that info from the Sens
ERS that are actually built into the
mattress cover I use at this point I'm
sure you've heard of eight sleep and the
Pod mattress cover that you know warms
up and cools down each side of the bed
independently automatically so that
thing not only helps you sleep better by
automatically changing the temperatures
but then it also monitors how you sleep
it's got the sensors inside and then it
delivers a report for you so you just
open the app every morning you get this
personalized report that shows you
things like your heart rate variance
respiratory rate you know how your sleep
stages panned out overnight so I think
I'm officially done wearing any
wearables to sleep for any sleep
tracking data just because this handles
it all now I've actually talked about
them before and I saw a lot of your
comments about eight sleep and so I
chatted with eight sleep about them and
was able to get them to offer a little
bit more functionality to people who are
new like first time signing up so
they'll actually now no matter what your
membership level they will give you a
free sleep report every 6 months so it's
not behind any sort of pay wall so
thanks to eight sleep for sponsoring
this video I'm happy to report that
they're also offering you guys the
largest discount that they ever have so
if you want to check it out feel free to
check out the link in the description
and use code MKBHD so now that I'm not
wearing it to sleep I am able to charge
the cmf watch every night like I said
it's got this little magnetic pin
charger technically not as pretty as
those fancy wireless charging pucks but
honestly pretty close and the battery
life I've realized is really really good
because of how simple it is again just a
Bluetooth accessory not a whole ton of
processing power needed on their site
they're claiming like 13 days of regular
use I don't know if I'm going to get
that but but I was able to get three
straight days easy no problem and I'm
sure you could probably use power saver
mode and get even more if you wanted to
so it's got better battery life than an
Apple Watch but really the main thing
that I learned when testing this watch
is it turns out this is actually a
pretty expensive watch in its segment
$69 is on the premium end for a very
basic Smartwatch it's actually pretty
common for the cheapest most basic
SmartWatches to be in the 20 to $50
range and you know at that point they're
all more or less the same product
they're all a simple plasticky Bluetooth
accessory with some slightly different
designs so this the cmf watch Pro is a
slightly better package slightly better
design slightly better looking version
for a slight upcharge kind of the same
way nothing is probably charging a
little bit more than you would expect
for a phone with the same specs just
because of the design and the nice stuff
they do with it that's that's what this
is too and I bring up nothing because
cmf is nothing's Ultra budget sub brand
and they actually do some other stuff
like earphones Chargers same deal
extremely cheap products but just marked
up a little bit for nice packaging and
nice design so here I I'll leave you
with this cmf in the industries
typically stands for color material
finish it's the name of the company but
it's also what those letters stand for
and the cmf of this Smartwatch is it's
very much still silverish finger printy
technically metal but feels kind of
plasticky but if you squint enough the
square kind of looks like an Apple Watch
Ultra and if that's your comparison
point then this thing is a total bargain
so I think that was what their real goal
was yeah if you want to get one of these
things you can it is maybe a little more
challenging to get it in the US maybe if
you import it spend a couple extra
dollars then you're competing with some
other SmartWatches but it's an option
but now you know
exists the more you know thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace